in our series a more perfect union we
aim to show you that what unites us as
Americans is far greater than what
divides us this morning we introduced
you to a Minnesota boy who's on a
mission to brighten the lives of others
who cannot see colors CBS this morning
Saturday co-host Michelle Miller is here
Michelle this all started with a pair of
glasses a pair of glasses just like
these special pair of glasses can color
even the darkest corners color blindness
affects one in every 12 males and 1 in
every 200 females and when they get
those colors turned on it opens up a
whole new spectrum of possibilities when
11 year old Taylor imager slipped on a
pair of these special glasses
his reaction said it all it changed just
everything looks different the glasses
are designed to bring color into a drab
world they allow the color blind to see
the vivid hues they've been missing I
just like to see what everybody else
sees Tate can do that now thanks in part
to seventh grader Jonathan Jones in his
mom Carol all years
back in November Jonathan got the chance
to try out these glasses as part of his
science class and when the video of this
tearful reaction to seeing colors went
viral offers to help started pouring in
so many people both people we knew and
people we'd never heard from in our
lives we're reaching out to us and
sending mediums asking to give money
towards Jonathan's glasses Jonathan's
family set up a GoFundMe page not to pay
for his glasses but to buy a pair for
another child they asked for three
hundred and fifty dollars before he went
to bed that night we were at $1,000 and
we're currently at 32 32 that's right
Jonathan and his family raised nearly a
hundred times more than they had asked
over 32,000 dollars and when the company
that makes the glasses in chroma heard
about it they committed to match the
donation which could provide at least a
hundred and 30 pairs more
I wear these glasses 24/7 because you
know colors amazing so on a cold morning
just before Christmas in Cottonwood
Minnesota a small group of kids gathered
in the gym at the Lakeview school to get
their glasses enabling them to see color
for the first time like nine-year-old
Brendan Carroll's amazing and it's also
really um I think experience for me to
see the actual colors to things and it's
just really nice to see that other
people can see that too watching other
people discover color for the first time
is an emotional experience of its own
it's just little things that I notice
throughout the day like driving down the
street the green signs the red stop
signs there's a red house in our
backyard and I put them on it was like
watching my hands at the kitchen sink
and I was like wow that is red Wow is
right well the Jones family plans to
keep their donations in-state but
eventually they want to help color blind
kids all around the country and you look
at those reactions especially they're so
powerful people who were older for the
first time are seeing something they've
never seen before just amazing and it
will say it's not the most important
thing but the thick frame glasses are
basically sunglasses indoors and thank
you so much
you